[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN VEIZADES: Hey, everybody.
Good afternoon and welcome
to the last session of Next.
Thanks for all sticking
around for this.
Today we're honored to have five
of our third-party vendors come
up and talk about
how they extend
your networks to the
cloud and still maintain
the level of
security and privacy
and functionality that
you traditionally have
in your enterprise network.
So today, we'll have Sherry from
Aviatrix talking about SSL/VPN,
Ajay from Brocade
talking about WAFs, Erez
from Check Point talking about
their next-gen firewall, Marc
from F5 talking about
their load balancer,
and finally Jigar from
Palo Alto also talking
about a next-gen firewall.
So without further ado, I'm
turning it over to Sherry.
Thank you, Sherry.
SHERRY WEI: Thanks, John.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming by.
I'm Sherry.
I'm founder and CTO of Aviatrix.
We are a start-up company
in Silicon Valley.
Can you switch to my slide?
Oh, yeah.
JOHN VEIZADES: The other one.
SHERRY WEI: The other one.
JOHN VEIZADES: They swapped.
Put it on the regular--
SHERRY WEI: Yeah, it's
to be on one display.
OK.
JOHN VEIZADES: There you go.
SHERRY WEI: Yeah.
OK.
Yeah.
So Aviatrix is a company
based in Silicon Valley.
Our mission is to
make cloud networking
as simple and dynamic
as compute and storage.
With Aviatrix, the
cloud networking
become a substrate
in your full stack,
and we take care of
that, so that you
can focus on building awesome
applications and services.
So how do we do that?
Traditionally, you know
how networking devices, the
approaches you deploy.
It's very much hardware-based.
You deploy the device and
you configure and deploy
another one.
You configure it.
We take a totally
different approach.
In our approach,
there is a controller.
It's a software, more
defined approach, where
you started with a controller.
The controller is deployed
either on prem or in the cloud.
And the controller is given
credentials, the cloud
credentials, so that it can
use APIs to launch gateways
in the cloud in the
network of your choice.
And from there on, you
can build IPSec tunnels,
or you can build SSL/VPNs
through all point-and-click
or REST API-driven.
So if you think about
cloud networking,
it really has all three parts.
Either you're talking about
connecting from on prem
to the cloud, or you're
talking about connecting
from cloud to cloud,
or talking about user
connecting to the cloud.
And we have the product
for all three capabilities,
for all three, for all
the major cloud providers.
And in addition to that,
in terms of IPSec VPN,
we also have scale-out
solution where
you can deploy a cluster
of gateways in case
you want to have a
communication of throughput
that more than a single
instance based performance.
And today, I'm going to focus
on one of the capabilities we
have, which is a user VPN.
It's SSL based.
Now, if you are a
enterprise customer,
you probably wonder,
why do I need SSL/VPN?
I already have that
for my corporate IT,
and then I connect
it to the cloud.
But you'd be surprised
how our customers use
our device, this capability.
With the cloud, what you can do
is let's say you have partners
and you have contractors.
Traditionally, you bring
them on prem to your DMZ,
and that create a
lot of security risk
and a lot of complications.
With the cloud, you can actually
set up a cloud network project
account for them, and you
meet them in the cloud
and you give them
certain permissions,
but you have complete
control to it.
And that's one of the
very popular case,
even for enterprise to
use these capability.
Now, you say, if I'm a start-up,
why do I care about SSL/VPN?
Of course, if you, let's say,
at the most basic challenges
for user access, is let's
say you have nothing on prem,
everything is in
the cloud, then you
need to have your
developers accessing.
Now, without any VPN capability,
you either deploy everything
in a public subnet, which
means you invite attacks
on your public-facing
instances, or you
do some kind of jump
bastion station or jump
host where you log
in to one instance
and get to the other one.
In either case, the key
management and secure access
become a challenge, even
for start-up companies,
because most of your
instances, your database,
your application, should
be put in private.
They should not have
public-facing access.
So what's a unique thing about
Aviatrix's SSL/VPN solution?
We build ground-up for the
cloud deployment in the--
for example, let's
say the SSL/VPN,
how do you manage
multi-factor authentication?
We integrate with the
dual [INAUDIBLE] LDAP,
and we are the only
open VPN-based provider
that supports SAML
integration, so that you
can integrate with your own
enterprise identity management
and have single
sign-on into the cloud.
And so how do we
load balancing VPN,
if I cannot have a single
instance, and if that fail,
what do I do?
Because most of virtualized
appliance put in the cloud
is a single instance based.
We provide a Google-native
load balancer
based VPN solution where you
can scale out to thousands
of tens of thousands of users.
The largest internet streaming
company use our product
for the VPN access.
So that's scaling out.
How do we manage users?
We have this called
profile-based access,
where you can assign users--
your contractors, your partners,
your DevOps, your employees--
and you can give security
policies when they connect to,
and it will push down to the
gateway where they landed,
and it will stop them from
accessing their permitted
resources at the gateway level.
So there is a profile based.
And then how do we do logging?
How do we do logging?
Again, we integrate with
all the popular-- we
don't want to have another
dashboard to look at events.
We integrate with the Splunk,
Sumo Logic, Logstash, Datadog,
so that you can have complete
visibility to all the TCP
sessions.
All the network
events are completely
logged to your
central log-in system.
And another powerful
thing about this solution
is because we do also IPSec
VPN, so you can integrate it
with that, meaning
that when a user landed
into cloud, together
with the VPN access,
they can actually
access any cloud
network, any instances
with the profile-based,
with the multi-factor
authentication,
and with all logging
capability built in.
So that's kind of--
this is the solution we provide.
Next, I want to show you a demo
about how this thing works.
Can we switch to demo?
OK.
So what you see here is
actually the Aviatrix controller
dashboard, which shows a
topology of all the deployment
you have, and these icons
are actually the gateways
in different cloud.
And we also monitor
latencies, constantly
monitor latency alert messages.
The green lines are the
peering connectivity
you build between clouds
or between projects,
and the dotted line are
the HA back-up lines.
So now I'm going to show you,
in this particular set-up
I have for the SSL, I have
dual and LDAP integration.
So I'm going to show you
how this stuff works.
I'm going to log in.
This is a simple
Tunnelblick VPN.
And so I will be
prompt user name.
This is my LDAP.
And I'm also getting dual push
onto my phone to authenticate.
And once these two factors
get authenticated in,
I'm assigning IP address.
Now I can access resources
with all private IP address.
So for example, I have
a website called--
it's a 10.10.0.21.
It's one of the
gateways in my set-up,
so I can access security.
I have permission for that.
And if you look
at the dashboard,
it shows that I connected
with the profile.
I connected as Sherry with
the profile Operations.
And in the meantime, all the
TCP sessions where I browse
will be all forward to, in this
case, we integrate with Splunk,
which has all the top talkers,
top data, who had logged in
for how long, and all the
messages, all the information
you would need.
So that concludes the demo.
Can I switch back to the--
yeah, OK.
So that is our SSL/VPN
with cloud integration.
So I went through this demo, and
that concludes my presentation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AJAY BHARADWAJ: Hi, everyone.
Good afternoon.
My name is Ajay Bharadwaj.
I'm responsible for the virtual
ADC roadmap and strategy
at Brocade.
So what I'm going to talk to
you in the next 10 minutes or so
is about our ADC and WAF
solutions on Google Cloud.
Before I tell you
the why, let me
rewind a little
bit, a few years,
and show you how load balancing
deployments have changed.
I'm sure my
colleagues here would
agree to how that is happening.
Enterprises used to deploy
a large load balancer
in their data center and then
hang several dozen applications
off it.
What we're seeing now with
cloud-based deployments
is that the mode of deployment
is slightly changing.
So we're having more number of
load balancers being deployed,
but lesser number of
applications being
hung off each load balancer.
What that really means
is the deployment,
the number of
deployments are clearly
increasing, because you have
more number of those instances
being deployed.
But at the same time, the
lifecycle for those deployments
were also changing.
So you may want to
spin up and down
an instance at short notice and
service a set of application
workloads that are in the cloud
at a certain point in time,
necessarily available for a
user at a certain point in time,
or not.
So that's one of the
trends that we're seeing.
And with the Brocade virtual
ADC solution, first of all,
it's purpose-built
for the cloud.
So we never sold, you know, the
virtual ADC as a hardware box.
It was built with cloud
and virtualization
in mind from the very inception.
And that's why it's optimized
for any cloud anywhere
kind of an environment.
The ease of
programming, the ease
of flexibility of applying
business logic on the box,
is greatly simplified
by the scripting
tools we offer on the system.
And most importantly,
the ability
to have customized licensing,
or flexible licensing,
plays a role here.
Now again, if you
go back to what
I mentioned about
instances being spun
up and down at short
notice, the piece
that would stick out
there is, how do you
license those instances
at short notice as well?
So you can't really
have a static tie-in
of the license
with that instance
and then keep that
available for very long,
because you don't
need that instance.
You might want to
reuse the license
at a different deployment
at a separate point in time.
So that's where our
flexible licensing
model comes into play, and it's
truly unique across the market.
So a few key things on where
we continue to add value.
So let's take health
checks, for example.
So load balancing is
clearly a solution
where you want to monitor
the health of your appliances
or the back-end nodes and
only load balance traffic
if the node is actually up.
Well, what you can do
with Brocade's solution is
you can do not
just one hop away,
you can actually do multi-hop.
So for example, if a web server
is connected to a database
and your ability to
load balance really
depends on the availability
of the database,
you can do the multi-hop
kind of a situation.
So you don't load
balance to a web server
if the database tied
to it is actually down,
because it doesn't
make sense, right?
I mean, you may need
information from the database
when it's actually
not available.
The other key piece here
is speed and reliability.
So we've measured one of the
highest throughput measurements
in the industry for a virtual
solution on a single instance.
We go up to upwards
of 140 gigabits
per second of throughput on
a single virtual instance.
Now, if you think about
certain use cases,
like object storage,
where a lot of traffic
is being pumped through
a load balancer,
these become
critically important,
especially when you have a
single instance funneling
a lot of traffic.
I talked about scripting as
an important differentiator
for what we have.
Now that, again, translates
to if you can describe
your problem, how do you apply
request and response rules
on your load balancer
such that it's
able to translate
the business logic
into actual
decision-making rules?
So what we have
built in is a GUI.
So let's say your problem
that you want to solve is
if you're load balancing to
an e-commerce credit card
processing node, unless
the response time is--
if the response time happens to
be greater than x milliseconds,
then you don't want to
balance to that node,
because clearly
something might be wrong.
Maybe the credit card processing
engine is not working.
You may want to, at that point,
redirect your credit card
request to a different
web server that
can process that transaction.
So what TrafficScript
would do is essentially
look for a response
from the node
and take an intelligent
decision based
on what kind of
business logic you want
to apply for that situation.
So if your logic dictates that
if the transaction time is
greater than x
milliseconds, then please
redirect me to a node
where things are actually
processed faster.
From an end user
perspective, all you see
is maybe the little wheels
spin a few milliseconds extra,
but your transaction
has processed
much faster because of the
request and response rules
that you've applied.
So let me talk a little
bit about the pieces
within the portfolio.
What we have is the
traffic manager, which
is the load balancing piece.
We have a web application
firewall, which does
[INAUDIBLE], top 10, you
know, attack detection.
It resides in the same module
as the traffic manager.
So as long as you can
deploy the traffic manager,
you get web application
protection as well.
And then we have the
services director,
which is responsible for
licensing, orchestration,
management of these instances.
Again, going back
to my first point
on the importance of being
able to manage the ADC
estate, if you will, especially
in a cloud environment,
is critically important.
So together with these
three components,
it forms the virtual
ADC family that we have.
So let me talk about two use
cases that are relevant here.
The first one is hybrid cloud.
Now clearly, if you're
born in the cloud,
you have a certain set of
options for the load balancing
solution that you choose.
If you are a traditional, if
you were on prem to start with,
you have a certain
set of solutions.
But a lot of the
enterprises we see
are in the lift and shift phase.
So as you're moving your
application workloads
from on prem to
cloud, the ability
to load balance across the
moving set of workloads
becomes relevant as well.
So I think that's
one of the key areas
that we see which
is growing, and we
find that most of the
enterprises are in both places,
right?
So that's where we're seeing
the application workloads
shift, and the ability
for us to load balance
there becomes important.
The other one is, again,
proactive security control.
So as you deploy your
applications in the cloud,
what kind of security controls
can you exercise from a layer 7
perspective?
So clearly, your
layer 3 firewall
can only protect what it
can, but it can't really
do things like URL protection
on the URL and things like that,
which are more
application-centric,
and you may need
additional controls
on the application
side, which actually
prevent layer 7 attacks.
So that's where
the WAF comes in.
Again, on Google Cloud, we
have both the virtual traffic
manager and the WAF available
through the launcher, so you
can obviously just pick
one of them and then--
or both, the combination,
and then launch through GCP.
So I wanted to kind of
emphasize the impact
we've had with GCP presence.
So we launched this
back sometime last year,
and we've seen tremendous
growth in the amount of usage
across WAF and
our load balancing
solution in Google Cloud.
So I think that clearly
goes to show, first of all,
there's a lot of interest in
the foundation and the cloud
environment that
Google has set up.
And secondly, there is
a tremendous opportunity
that's ahead of us as well, in
terms of applications moving
to Google, and at the
same time, the network
elements and the solutions
that support application
movement need to be
carefully assessed as well.
So that's all I had
today, and thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
EREZ BERKNER: Hi, everybody.
My name is Erez Berkner
from Check Point,
and what I would
try to cover today
is take one of the main use
cases of customers moving
to the cloud, talk about the
security challenges of that use
case, talk about how Check Point
allow you to secure and address
the different challenges of
that use case, and show a demo.
And all of this in 10 minutes--
sorry, nine.
John runs a tight shift here.
So hang tight.
You're ready for this?
Yes.
I need a little bit more energy.
Ready for this?
Thank you.
OK, great.
So hang on.
So a little bit
about Check Point.
Check Point was founded in 1993.
Since 1997, we're
been Gartner's leaders
in advanced security
in the Magic Quadrant,
more than $1.7 billion
in revenues last year,
more than 4,000 employees
and over 100,000 customers,
and we've protecting
cloud since 2008, and up
to this day with all
major cloud providers.
And the use case I
chose to talk to you
about is protecting
your web servers.
So customer moving
to the cloud, wanting
to put his workloads
on the cloud,
enjoy the electricity
and scalability
of his web presence.
So of course, he would need
to run Google instances
on the cloud that will scale
up and down as he needs.
In this example,
I chose a customer
who decided to keep his
databases on premise.
So he have his
on-premise presence
where his database are.
And this customer also want
to allow his remote workers
to do remote maintenance
on his cloud web servers.
So this is kind
of the environment
I want to talk about.
I'm going to talk about
challenges of this environment.
There are several.
First of all, Google allow--
any cloud provider allow you
to segment your environment.
That's very, very important.
But that's the basics.
So you want to segment your
production from your dev,
from your test.
That's needed, and
that's a basic.
But segmentation is not enough.
You need to be able to
look into the transaction,
to look into the web request, to
look what is going from the web
to the application
to the database,
and be able to say whether this
is a legitimate transaction
or it is a malware trying
to propagate, because today,
you cannot segment at the
actual virtual machine level,
because everything is connected,
everything is hyperconnected,
web to application to database
to web servers to CRM,
et cetera.
This is what the
business today requires.
So one of the things you
need to be careful about
is having a server
in your environment
infected and that
infection spreading
within your environment.
So it's enough to have
one server infected,
if you don't have
the right means
to get your entire segment,
your entire environment,
infected with malware.
So this is kind of one
of the main concerns
of this environment.
The other is, how do I connect
this threaded data center which
is on premise and off
premise in the cloud,
how do I connect
it in a secure way?
I want to allow my remote
employees to connect securely
to the web servers, and I want
the web servers to be able
to connect securely
to the database,
because I want to be able to
avoid man-in-the-middle attacks
or someone sniffing and
looking at my private data.
So this is concern, the second
concern I wanted to talk about.
So this is exactly what
Check Point with Google
work together in order
to provide customers.
This product name, our product
family name, is called vSEC.
This is our Check Point
solution for cloud security.
And we are announcing today a
Check Point vSEC 4 Google Cloud
Platform.
And I'm going to show you how
vSEC allows you to actually
answer those challenges.
But before we move on,
I do want to mention
that vSEC is a
cross-cloud solution,
so we're supporting all the
major cloud vendors today,
starting from on-premise
VMware software-defined network
and Cisco and AWS and
Azure and OpenStack
and [INAUDIBLE]
and Alibaba Cloud
and now Google, which is
very strategic and important
step for Check Point.
And vSEC allow you to
have a persistent security
policy managing your assets
from different clouds.
So if you have a multi-cloud,
you're using GCP and AWS
and you have on-premise
VMWare and GCP,
you have one security
policy managing everything,
including your physical
on-premise devices.
So let's go back to the
scenario we've discussed.
So we have our web
apps, and now let's
say we add vSEC, deploying
this within Google Cloud.
So first of all, we need to
care about attacks originating
from external, because
a virtual machine
in the cloud with public IP
is under constant attack.
And the attackers need
to succeed only once,
and you guys need to be able
to stop them 100% of the time.
So first and foremost, we
need to inspect the packets,
we need to inspect
the transaction,
to understand whether
there is some threat
on those transactions.
So vSEC protect you
from external threats.
This is north-south security,
from external to your data
center in the cloud.
And vSEC allow you to stop
malware before it arrives.
So if the malware arrive,
vSEC will identify, block it,
and log the event.
More than that, if
we think forward,
we talked about the fact
that even if somehow a server
got infected, we don't
want this to spread around.
So vSEC provides you
east-west security
within the environment,
between the data center,
so malware is not able
to propagate laterally
moving within the environment.
This is east-west
threat prevention.
Our remote workers can now use
SSL/VPN with the same device
in order to have
encrypted connections
to the environment,
and of course,
site-to-site VPN covering our
web-to-database transaction.
All of this with
a single solution.
It's the same solution.
It's the same engine.
A few more points about this.
First of all, this is
unified management.
You have one consistent policy.
You're able to use Google
objects within your security
policy, and whenever anything
changes, IP changes, et cetera,
this automatically adapt.
No manual operation
you need to do.
This is very, very
strong around automation.
So it's one-click provisioning.
It scales automatically
as you need,
so you can scale linearly as
you need more security power.
And it provides auto-protection.
Your virtual machine is there.
You don't need to do anything.
It will be protected
automatically.
It's open, in terms everything
is API-based and CLI-based.
Very strong in terms
of performance.
We have over five
gigs of throughput
of performance per
VM with four cores,
and you can adjust
it as you like.
And we are partnering
with VMWare very strongly
on the R&D and product side,
so we're supporting many beta
and alpha features
like the XPN, which
is very, very strong offering.
I won't have time
to talk about it,
but I'm guessing some of
you know it, multi-NIC.
And we're having test
drive to allow you to test
our solution very easily.
So I want to do a quick demo.
I wish I could.
OK.
This is live movie.
So anything can go wrong.
So this is a Google launcher.
We are on Google launcher.
You choose whether you
want pay as you go,
which is Google-based,
or a Check Point license.
And on this template, you
choose how many cores you like,
what is the region, which
networks you want to secure,
and whether you want
this to be standalone
or a part of a larger
management you have on premise.
And you click Submit,
and that's it.
On the background now, a new
virtual machine is created.
The networks are
being connected.
The interfaces of the Check
Point vSEC is being created.
The IPs are being assigned.
And if we log in to the web
interface of Check Point,
you will be able to see that--
this is Check Point--
identifies this as Google,
Google Cloud Platform,
because we need to use all the
Google object and integration.
And you can see all the
interfaces are up already,
with IPs which are configured
automatically by the system.
And that's it.
And the device is up.
So very, very easy
to take this and move
from an environment
not protected
to environment fully
protected by Check Point.
OK, I'm going to run through
this because John is giving me
kind of a hint.
But I do want to--
couple of slide about how
this actually looks like.
So this is what you get
at the end of the day.
This, for example, is a
report of access control.
Which application are running,
which users are running, which
IPs, what threats do you have?
This is an example
of threat prevention.
Which threats do you have?
Do you have malware?
How many?
Where?
Which geographies, et cetera?
And this is [INAUDIBLE]
for remote access,
so I currently have 33 connected
remote access and user.
I can drill down.
Anything here is clickable.
Very, very nice.
Last slide, John.
Any start-ups in the cloud?
Just me?
OK.
So for you, sir, we're going
to have a new start-up program.
It's not published yet.
So next week it's
going to be published.
We're going to give one
year of free security--
this is joint by Check
Point and Google.
If you're interested,
just contact me.
We have the launcher.
We also have a Check
Point in test drive.
So we can just run it on
Check Point environment.
You don't need to pay anything
to get the feeling of how
this actually behaves.
And you are welcome to follow
us for more updates on product
and features which we have.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MARC CHISINEVSKI: Good
afternoon, everybody.
My name is Marc Chisinevski
from F5 Networks.
Before we begin, could
we have a quick show
of hands, how much of you
are F5 customers or partners?
OK, quite a few.
So for those of
you who know F5, we
are simply bringing all the
breadths of F5 solutions
that we are currently using
to Google Cloud Platform.
And for those of you who
do not know F5 Networks,
we are an advanced
load balancer.
We are an application security
and remote access controller.
And also, last but not least,
we are a programmable proxy.
And we will cover a
bit more about that
when we discuss our
integration with Kubernetes.
The F5 vision is
to enable customers
to use our traffic management
and security capacities across,
regardless of whether you
deploy your application
in a public cloud or
on premise or even
in a cloud-native environment,
such as Kubernetes.
So regardless of whether you
have workloads in Google Cloud
Platform or Google
Container Engine,
so manage Kubernetes
or some other clouds
and on-premise
deployments, you should
be able to apply your security
policies and load balancing
policies in a consistent manner.
So in terms to make it easy for
customers to deploy all that,
we are integrating
with Cloud Launcher.
In addition to
that, we are going
to provide Google deployment
templates for our solutions.
And if you look at our
github.com/F5Networks,
we will have a lot of examples
of fully deploying our virtual
edition for Google Cloud with
Terraform as well, for example.
May I ask how many
of you are using
systems such as Terraform?
OK.
And maybe Ansible as well?
OK, understood.
Thank you.
So now we have some,
it's not a long time
to cover all of this
solution, of course.
I do want to cover a little bit
of our Kubernetes integration
as well.
So this is a separate product
from the F5 BIG-IP product
that you know.
It's basically a
component provided by F5
that runs natively
inside Kubernetes,
and it will just monitor
the Kubernetes services
that you have deployed,
gather all the information
on the [INAUDIBLE]
that are available,
and just populate the F5
devices automatically.
So this means, it's just an
example at what I've previously
mentioned with the
F5 vision, it enables
you to deploy your traffic
management, load balancing,
and security policies and
remote access policies
in a consistent manner.
So BIG-IP will know,
our devices will
know what happens in Kubernetes,
what workloads are available,
how we can access
those, and therefore
the device will be able to
apply all the security policies
and load balancing policies.
That, of course, also
means that, as I said,
all our features-- in terms
of load balancing, security,
remote access, and VPN-- will
be available in Google Cloud.
So this also means that, given
that our virtual edition,
represented as VE there in
the middle of this diagram,
will have all the information
about your different
environments and will
be able to also know
what happens inside your
Kubernetes clusters.
And again, it
doesn't really matter
if it's about Kubernetes
running on premise
or in GCP or as managed
Kubernetes in Container Engine.
So again, all the features.
If all this is interesting for
you, we have a beta program.
Sorry for the very big font.
So we have a beta program.
You can try that.
We also have a free F5
edition that you can
try with all the feature set.
You can try that for free,
at least on our side.
It is free.
So you can test
all these features.
And I think that kind
of concludes little bit
[INAUDIBLE].
Perfect.
Perfect timing.
So we'll have a lot more
time, I hope, for questions,
and also we have our team
working on these integrations.
Our product managers
are here, so we
can stay after the session
to discuss specifics
about all these different
features in GCP, Container
Engine, and also, of course,
other requirements you
might have.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JIGAR SHAH: So my
name's Jigar Shah.
I'm a product manager
at Palo Alto Networks.
I focus on public
cloud security.
And first, before
I begin, I'd like
to just make the usual
disclaimer in the sense
that we haven't
launched yet on Google,
but we've been very
closely working.
We've obviously got
a lot of customers
who have got physical
firewalls from us
that connect over hybrid
cloud into the Google Cloud
environment.
And we're working towards
launching the virtual edition
on the platform.
Right, so that's the usual,
legal guys made me do it.
But it's actually true.
So you should look
at that, and say,
don't make any purchasing
decisions based on that.
We're working very closely
with the Google team on this.
So in terms of
technical concepts,
let's go little bit
backwards and look at,
what is the public cloud
security architecture?
It's a shared security model.
Google takes care of the
security of the platform,
and they've got a lot of
amazing technologies and tools
that, for example, Erez
mentioned a few of them.
There's IAM, there's
basic firewall rules,
and there's all this
physical security
protection of the cloud itself.
But once a packet hits
the VPC or the network
that you deployed, you are
responsible for it's security.
You can use all the tools,
like IAM, Google Cloud firewall
rules, all those elements.
But you still have
to do that work,
and you have to make sure
you configure them correctly,
follow all the best
practices, which
is sort of normally
what you would do.
So now, in this
environment, what
is the specific
difference or the value
add of a next-gen firewall?
So typically, if you
look at an attack that
happens, if you were looking
to prevent an attack,
you first want
complete visibility.
Whether it's on prem
or in the cloud,
you need visibility so
that you are actually
able to see the traffic and
decide if there is actually
a threat or not.
The second element
you would have to do
is also reduce the
attack surface.
So for example, if
it's a web application,
you may configure the basic
Google Cloud firewall rules,
and say, allow port
80 and 443 only.
Good security best practices.
If it's a specific
application, you're
going to only allow those
application traffic streams
to go through that solution.
And then comes the real part,
is that any application that
is out there is where
the attackers are looking
to exploit vulnerabilities.
Anything you hear about
exploits, malware,
all they're trying to do
is exploit vulnerabilities
in the application.
So you want to know
all the known threats.
These are the CVs or
the vulnerabilities
that are posted, and then
you're trying to prevent them.
That's step number one.
That, you got to do
basically day in,
day out, prevent
known vulnerabilities.
Next comes the more
interesting, tricky part.
When new vulnerabilities
are found by researchers
or by attackers,
how quickly do you
turn around and make them
sort of known vulnerabilities
and quickly start protecting
as soon as you can?
So these can be zero-day
attacks, or even
brand new variations
of known attacks.
So to do this, there's a lot of
things that go under the hood
to make this possible.
So on the visibility front,
you see all the things
that you have to do.
To reduce the attack surface,
there's all these other things
to do.
So I'm not going to go
through all the details,
but let's take an example.
So for example, if
there is a malware,
it's trying to exploit
a specific application.
Let's say, some bug in NGINX
or some coding issue in NGINX,
the malware is trying
to exploit that.
What they're probably
going to try to do is,
what are all the
relevant applications
that need to be
controlled, where
this malware is impacting it?
You also want to
potentially look at,
from the visibility
perspective, is that,
is the traffic
actually encrypted,
and pretty much 70%, 80%
or more of the traffic
is now going towards
encrypted traffic.
So potentially, the solution
that protects you also
needs to do SSL
decryption, because you
have to actually look
at the encrypted traffic
to see if there's actually
malware going through
or it's benign traffic.
So there's a lot
of elements that
are needed to sort of provide
that full application stack
security.
And this is really hard to do.
I've got all these
bullet points,
but there's a lot of components
that go underneath it.
And the last part that
I'm not talking fully
is that beyond just cloud and
on prem, that unknown prevention
part.
That's where a lot of the secret
sauce comes in these days--
applying dynamic
analysis, static analysis,
applying machine learning
to say what is benign,
what is malicious?
So there's all these
components that
are needed to truly
secure an environment.
So let me give you the
example in a different way.
So if you configure the
base security that's
available with the
firewall rules,
this is a 5-tuple
rule available.
So it'll say,
source destination,
allow this protocol port.
That's how you
would configure it.
Obviously, there's
a lot more that
goes into it from that
visibility perspective
that I was talking about.
It's not just that it's a
344-kilobyte transaction.
It's actually an SSL traffic
that is carrying HTTP packets.
So this is your
application, which is HTTP.
What if you really
needed to know more
to make a decision on
whether to allow it?
What would be ideal is that if
you know what user is involved
and where is the actual
traffic going to?
So you know the IP,
but you'd rather
like to know the geolocation, if
it's relevant to your use case.
You may want to block traffic
going to certain countries.
And specifically, what is the
application going through?
So if you look at
the bottom line,
that's the simple 5-tuple rule.
Imagine this was
an outbound flow
from your environment
that's going out
to some location in
Canada, essentially,
as I'm showing here.
What if, instead of
this benign flow,
where a PDF file
is going through,
instead with all
those same details,
but actually instead
of that PDF file,
it's actually a pre-executable
with some malware inside it.
There's no way you
would know that you
need to block this
or allow this,
because the basic port protocol
stuff, the bottom rules,
will allow this.
So this is what you need
to sort of essentially
go ahead and protect.
So to do this, we're
obviously working
to bring the next-generation
firewall to the Google Cloud
Platform.
And the product is
called VM-Series.
It runs the same PAN-OS
code, the operating system,
and all the security features
that our customers have
used on prem, and now
it's going to be available
when we launch in the
Google Cloud environment.
So I've got a simple demo
that's in our trade show--
sorry, on our floor booth,
so you can come take a look.
I'm not running
through the demo here.
But essentially, the idea is
that now that Google Cloud
supports a true
multi-NIC environment,
it's going to allow
you to do really
good, clean segmentation.
For example, I've
got a firewall here
which has a connection in
the management network,
so that you can segment
management network
from your on-prem world.
Then, you can have a
public-facing interface
so that all your public-facing
traffic can come in.
You apply all the policies
that you would like,
and then you decide whether
it goes to the private network
where your applications
and services are running.
Now, on that private
network site,
you can also do segmentation
between application tiers
to say web server can
talk to database over SQL.
So things like that, all
those advanced logic and rules
can be applied so
that you really
make sure that inbound,
outbound, east-west flows can
be protected using those rules
that I was showing earlier.
Now, obviously the example
I showed a second ago
is kind of a simple layout.
You really are not going
to deploy at scale.
The cloud's all
about elasticity.
And the cloud
architecture really
is about scale out,
which means you
need to leverage the
cloud-native load balancers
and scale out behind
it to meet the demand.
So for example, I've
got this deployment
where the firewall is deployed
behind the external load
balancer, and applying
all the security policies
that you would like
inbound and outbound.
And the application stack
is deployed behind it.
Now, as your load grows--
oops.
Seems like I did not have
the animation picture here.
But essentially,
the idea would be
that when that application
stack scales out
horizontally and
adds more nodes,
you can now also
add more firewall
nodes to meet with demand, based
on the metrics that are pushed
to Stackdriver, for example.
So that would give you
a scale-out architecture
to deal with load and
elasticity of the cloud.
So in general, that example that
I gave is the rightmost one.
This is about internet
gateway perimeter security,
north-south.
The two other most
common use cases
for protecting
deployments in the cloud,
the leftmost one being hybrid
cloud, where a lot of customers
have on-prem networks that
are connecting into the Google
Cloud environment, and
they want to make sure
that that is connecting
securely and that if any VM
in the Google side
is compromised,
malware does not come
down, or somebody on prem
is not exfiltrating
data up to the cloud.
So you're trying to
make sure that you're
doing application-level security
and inspection for malware.
And the one in the middle
is about segmentation, which
is about making sure that--
let's say you have
one project deployed
which has a high
level of trust where
all your intellectual property
and important assets live,
and there's another project
which has lower level of trust.
You would like to
connect the two of them
so that there is
some data sharing,
but you want to do deeper
inspection between them.
So that's what a segmentation
architecture would look like.
That's about it.
If you want to know
more, you can come down
to the booth to learn more.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]